اسمح لي هايتي أن أسألك ، لقد مر أكثر من عامين فقط على مقتل
جمال بوحشية ،
أريد فقط أن أعرف كيف
تفعل وماذا
تشعر الآن اليوم ،
فأنا أشعر بأمل
أكثر وقوة من ذي
قبل وأنا  أبلي بلاءً حسنًا
وما زلت أتذكر جمال وأنا
أتحدث مع عالم بأسره حول العالم ،
وسأتحدث أه البرلمانات والأشخاص
الذين يهتمون بهذه القضية لا يزالون رائعون ،
دعني أسألك عن الفيلم بعد ذلك
لأنك  شارك في المنشق
كما يطلق عليه
وبعد عدة أشهر فقط من
القتل الرهيب وهناك مشهد
حيث
كنت داخل شقتك ،
كانت الشرطة هناك كل ما يخصك وجمال
الذي تعرف أن الأشياء منتشرة في كل مكان ،
أريد فقط أن أعرف
كيف  لقد ساعدك هذا الفيلم والتحدث علانية
في مدى أهمية هذا الفيلم
بالنسبة لك ،
ولا يمكنك تخيل مدى الصعوبة التي واجهتها ،
لكن في الوقت نفسه ، كنت
أنظر إلى المسيحية كنت
أحلم بمثل هذا الحب والسعادة
الذي وجدته أخيرًا مع جا  مال
ثم فجأة
أخذوا مني ، تم أخذها مني
، ولهذا السبب كان
وقتًا صعبًا للغاية في نفس الوقت ، إنه
وقت مهم جدًا
في ذهني في حياتي لأن الفيلم
يتحدث الآن عن القصة والفيلم
سوف  اجعل قصة جمال وإرثه على قيد الحياة
، ولهذا السبب تعرف الحقيقة في
الغالب أو مؤلمًا دائمًا
، لذلك قررت أن أتحدث ثم
أتحدث مع الناس ومن
ثم يحتاج العالم إلى فهم ما
حدث ،
أنا راضٍ عن هذا الفيلم و  ثم قام
براين بعمل جيد
جدًا ، ثم نحن جميعًا من حوله ، لقد
بقينا معه ثم ساعدناه
وساعدناه على
الانتشار وساعدنا جمال على الانتشار وكان
العمل جيدًا جدًا معه ، لقد
كنت شجاعًا جدًا تحدثت معه
البرلمانات التي خاطبتهم ، أعتقد
أن البرلمان الألماني الذي خاطبت
فيه البرلمان البريطاني ،
ما الذي تخبرهم به ماذا
تخاطبهم لأنني أتذكر ما حدث مع
جمال وأنا أطرح هذا السؤال
لماذا أنت  لا تفعل شيئًا مثل أي
شيء والآن قمة العشرين
المنعقدة وأنت شريك هذه القمة
لماذا أو كيف تجلس على نفس
الطاولة
مع شخص ما أه أمر قتل
جمال أو ما يحدث في بلادهم
غير مقبول ولا أحد
يعاقبهم وهناك  لا توجد محاكمة في بلدهم
وقد قاموا بتغطية هذه
الجريمة وأنت كشريك ،
فأنت تساعدهم فقط حتى
أوضح أنك تريدهم مقاطعة مجموعة العشرين
التي تحدث في
نهاية هذا الأسبوع أه عمليا
نعم بالطبع أنا أسأل  هذا أنا أسأل
أنه كيف يمكننا توقع هذا الوضع
الآن أنت
تجتمع الآن كقمة مجموعة العشرين في نفس الوقت
لديهم محاكمة في تركيا
ضد هؤلاء الرجال الذين كانت تلك
الإدارة
في تركيا في نفس الوقت في الولايات المتحدة
و  يا
رفاق المجتمع الدولي تفعل
شيئًا كأن
لا شيء يحدث بالطبع
تستضيف المملكة العربية السعودية قمة العشرين هذه ، وهذه هي
مشكلتك وهي تخرج من الرياض
لديك أيضًا وفجر مجموعتك
ستقاضي.  المملكة العربية السعودية ، أنت تقاضي mbs
كما هو معروف وتسعى للحصول على
تعويضات وتريد العدالة
يقولون إنهم قدموا أشخاصًا للمحاكمة
وقد أدانواهم ،
ما الذي تأمل في الخروج منه ،
نعم آمل  أه أجد العدالة
بعد هذا الصراع لأن أه
بالفعل غيروا حياتي بنسبة 100 في المائة
عندما يقتلون جمال يقتلون أيضًا
مستقبلي ويقتلون أيضًا آمالي أن يقتلوا أو
أيضًا
أحلامي ، لذا الآن لماذا نستمر في
القيام بنفس العلاقة والأعمال
والسياسة وأي صداقة مع
هؤلاء الأشخاص ،
لذا فإن قمة مجموعة العشرين
إذا قاطعتهم أو إذا
أخذوا أو قدموا أي بيان في
نفس الوقت
في بداية مجموعة العشرين فسيكون هذا
ردًا كبيرًا جدًا أه على ذلك.  هم والآن نقول
مع ذلك
لم ننس ما حدث جمال
ثم هناك حالات أخرى في
المملكة العربية السعودية بالمناسبة
أنا لا أتحدث عن حالة جمال فقط
قضية جمال
لأنه لا يوجد أمل جمال لن
أعود مرة أخرى.  لكن هناك بعض الأمل
للآخرين في السجن الآن